all right so beautiful hi
welcome back thank you for having me so
you've got
lots of interesting things that have
happened since the last time you were
here
yes i do which is only been a few months
right couple months probably
um tell me what's going on um i work for
a independent living home uh it's called
two-piece
from pain to pleasure was her idea for
it
um the lady's name is sybil she's very
nice she's the owner
she's given me a chance to work there
i've got about they upscaled me now i
had nine patients now i have 13
today so i'm graduating excelling
so you're working in a nursing home it
was independent living it's more
apartments that were turned into like
she brought this huge apartment complex
and each apartment has either a
a patient a nurse or just a patient
who's able
and capable of taking care of themselves
elderly a lot of elderly people
or mostly like if you say for instance
if you got hurt
and you weren't able but you're young
and they don't have a place for you and
your family can't deal with the type of
um treatment you need then they can put
you there too
because independent living they kind of
teach you how to live independently if
you can
if you can't be living independently
then they try to put a nurse
in your room with you live in that's
basically what it is
um they try to have everything on hand i
started here now
two weeks ago i believe actually it's
two weeks
today or tomorrow it's interesting it
keeps you very busy
yeah you're working like double shifts
oh my god it's crazy
don't forget the fact that if the
clients are under your knee
if they call you you've got to go in it
doesn't matter i feel like a doctor
yeah you told me yesterday you've just
finished a shift and then you had to go
to another
lady fell your boss called you and yeah
like okay
um your boss loves you because you're
like always i'm always there you're
ready willing and able to work
all the time i'm not gonna stop i love
it i'm starting at 17
an hour can't complain about that
um going from streetwalking to that so
what got you to make that change um kind
of this
doing this someone that's interested
my daughter's my 16 year old daughter
got pregnant
i have another granddaughter
and you have kids you're raising as well
huh you have kids that you're raising
yes i do so you're not you're not
you're not out there i'm not not out the
water yet so um
yeah it's hard because i've already got
six my sister died so i've got my niece
and my nephew
that i have to take care of too because
they're just like still kind of loopy
over that um my niece has oh my god four
kids herself and she's only 24.
and my nephew he doesn't have any kids
yet
he's trying to finish college um i don't
know i just feel like this was a
positive move for me
i really needed it like i was done
how do you say i felt like i was the
influence of my daughter having a baby
because some ways somehow they always
see what we do or they know
and like fragile innocence to me you
know they can always feel their parents
no matter what you know what i mean so i
feel like i played a part in that for
not being there
and now that i have them around me i
just had to send them somewhere
i needed a break because i couldn't
focus on my new job
and all of them and then my daughter has
a dog at the
hospital she works in radiology so
neither one of us and we're the oldest
she's 26 and i'm 44.
that's my oldest kid so we're pretty
much gone most of the time
so then i've got my 16 my 14 you know
what i mean kind of man and now so
that's
not good some of the kids are living
with you and some right so i sent
um six of them off to new jersey day
four yesterday
um no temporarily or permanently
temporarily oh no i love my babies
um they're the older ones left with them
let me see one two three
they took andriyna's kids and they took
one of my grandkids
um which was my son's son and i still
have zamaya with me which is my
granddaughter her name is beautiful too
so um yeah it's a family planning coming
together
i think my kids are happier now to be
around me
than they were because i was in you know
in and out it just was non-stop
my daughter was kind of embarrassed of
me but she's coming around now she's
actually calling me mom instead of
michelle
she always say michelle what do you now
she's like
mom so working the streets makes it a
very difficult lifestyle
like they feel like you're not a part of
them at all i really get hit in the
heart
big time my oldest daughter she's gonna
definitely make sure i feel it she's
just like what do you want michelle
i'm like wow first name basis really i
had you little girl
and she's like i'm not little anymore
i'm grown you're still my kid
you know um but they're smiling more now
she calls me a lot more now so i don't
feel like a big letdown
i'm going to keep this going until they
either elevate me or
i make something out of it it's a
blessing
thank you lord and i've got a good
support system behind me
and i've got good people trying to come
into my life now
so losing my parents losing my sister
it's just me and my baby brother and i
still haven't even seen him
so i guess i'm the last of the mohicans
so making the transition from working
the street on figueroa to doing this
is not easy right it's not easy at all
um even doing this
interviews and stuff the gentleman can i
say your name sure
okay well mark's been helping out a
great deal
i mean there's a lot of things that i
coming from the streets and then getting
a job i'm not making money
yeah so you haven't been paid yet at all
right so it's kind of like i get paid
this friday yay
so i have something to brag about um i'm
building steps right now so
every time i'm like if i need my id
mark's been there for me and you're
greatly highly appreciated you have no
freaking clothes for your car
or your whatever yeah mostly everything
bills rent
and but i gotta say it's really
uh it's paying off it's really rewarding
being able to help someone
have someone intercede when you can't do
for sale but from my side of the fence
it's really rewarding
to help somebody who's helping
themselves aggressively like i see you
working you
you were working all night you worked
literally you worked nice
morning you worked day you know seven
days a week you're right i got them at
two
and had to go right back out the floor
and then they let me off early like uh
30 to 45 minutes and i go home i mean no
sooner i went to sleep the phone was
ringing and i'm like dude
you guys serious there's nobody on so my
experience in helping
whether it's somebody on skid row or the
girls right oh your motivation is great
and
a lot of them the drugs come into play
and it really changes the whole
that's my thing i'm kind of seeing that
and you're drug free drug-free baby you
pretty much always have been right
yeah i smoke cigarettes so bad habit
yeah but
yeah as far as hard drugs now everyone
else i'm dealing with
the drugs come into play and it really
changes the interaction it changes the
way that
even their attitude the help becomes
enabling very quickly their attitude
becomes different and with you i see
that my help is
oh it's rewarding it's healthy and it's
actually getting
me it keeps me going it lets me know
that okay he's helping me now but i'll
be able to help myself later
and i'll be able to pay back somebody
that has stuck their neck out for me
which that's my goal so don't think
you're not thought about i'm not i'm not
holding you to that
i know but it's my goal you never ask me
for anything back
um you've actually been just you've been
a reward in my life that i never thought
i could even have yeah well i mean
from my side it's just so nice because
you're one of about out of 2 600 people
you're like one of about three or four
people
who have really taken the ball and done
the right thing and i appreciate the
compliment
because you're you're as solid as you
appear thank you
i appreciate because now you and i have
gotten to know each other and i see how
how incredibly responsible you are how
hard working you are how honest you are
you're always doing the right thing for
yourself and your kids and and your
employer and
me and everybody and it's just it's just
been delightful to interact with you
thank you
you're amazing i think the world of you
thanks
so do you miss working fig i'm sure
you're not really
only when i don't have money i kind of
think about it like
i gotta go get groceries i'm not gonna
want to call you all the time because
you're just like an intercessor but
then when i go outside on the streets
i'm just like
this is so not it anymore but it's it's
what are the emotions that that
lifestyle gives a woman
um stress belittling
sometimes you feel like you're miss it
you become very promiscuous
but i got um i'm more anti-social
than i was i don't even want people
really to see me is that is that i've
ever been with
is that shame very much so i feel it
um i have a high sex drive anyways
though
but to slow down and not even trip on
the streets like one day i am going to
have a partner
someday i don't know but it will happen
and i want to be able to clean myself
off
mentally and physically and spiritually
to where i don't have to um
balance that option out in my
relationship and i do not want my
partner to ever think
i'm going to run back off and because
i'm not getting enough at home or
whatever
whatever i'm going to go to the streets
i'm not that promiscuous i'm not an info
i just like what i like but other than
that
everything's going good and i'm thankful
for the opportunity for my employer as
well
yeah your employer sounds really great
too yeah i mean it just it took me
a lot of applications a lot of checking
and
um this is actually something that's um
heart calming
because of the type of people i'm
dealing with doing honest work
honest work and it's very hard call me
because trust me my life was
so now you have to take time with these
patients but do you feel like the shame
is fading away and
a little bit not much yet because i know
some of these people in this building
have been out and they've seen me and
and they're like i've seen you before
i'm like where you're changing your
story
yeah you're doing it by yourself yeah
i'm very proud of you darling thank you
very much i really appreciate you you're
amazing
all right keep it up most definitely
all right thank you all right yeah you
yeah that's cool